a single postage stamp costs 44 cents
how much would a roll of 1,000 stamps
cost so we're going to have 1,000 stamps
1,000 stamps and each of them cost 44
cents so we can multiply the thousand
stamps times 44 times we write that a
little neater times 44 cents per stamp
and then we just have to multiply the
two numbers now when you first multiply
decimals you can just pretend like
they're whole numbers and then worry
about the decimals later so we could
view this as a thousand times 44 and
then worry about the decimals so what's
a thousand times 44 you could work it
out you could say okay 4 times 0 is 0
and 4 times 0 0 4 times 0 0 4 times 1 is
a thousand or 4 times 1 is 4 you get
4,000 here then you put a 0 here and
you'd multiply that you'd get 40,000
you'd add it all up but I think we know
from experience dealing with multiplying
by powers of 10 or by multiples of 10
that you really 44 times a thousand is
just 44,000 so we could just write it
out here so 44 times 1,000 is 44 44 let
me not put a comma there just yet 44
44,000 that's 44 times a thousand now
this isn't 44 this is 0.44 so in both
numbers that were multiplying we have
exactly we have exactly one two numbers
to the right of the decimal so our
answer our product has to have two
numbers to the right of the decimal so
we count from the right we count one two
stick the decimal right there so our
answer is 440 and these trailing zeros
really add nothing there so 1,000 times
0.4 4 or 44 cents really is 440 or it's
going to cost us four hundred and forty
dollars to buy a thousand stamps which
makes sense because point four four
think about it it's it's well it's a
little bit less than half point five
would be half so this is a little bit
less than half of a thousand dollars
half would be five hundred this is a
little bit less